so my fridge I've just seen the finale
of the Mandalorian season 3. this video
will contain spoilers so if you have not
seen it yet click off now and click back
on this video once you have so overall
I'm gonna say this episode was
disappointed sure it was a good episode
I think it was a good episode but I felt
like it was way too rushed this episode
needed to be way longer than what I was
and there are also a lot of story
choices that I thought were quite
interesting and overall I thought
episode was very weak as well and I'll
explain everything to you guys right now
so firstly the pros of the episode I
like to say the action was really good
there was a very cool big battle scene
with auburn man Lawrence flying in a
really great battle scene with bogutan
grogu and Mando against moth Gideon and
as always the visuals and music were
great but a reflective writing could
have been so much better so firstly this
episode had no tension at all I don't
remember seeing one man Lauren died in
this whole entire episode and most feel
like moff Gideon's new Army just didn't
pay off like we watch the episode seven
right and there was just such a great
and big threat that was shown and then
there was just no payoff for that in
this episode the good guys won too easy
in my opinion and while we're on the
topic of moth get in I feel like he was
kind of like an afterthought so he comes
in the last two episodes and then he
just dies and I felt like we could have
had so much more with this character
there was so much potential especially
with the cloning right so we introduced
these clones of moth Gideon and then
they just get destroyed instantly like
for them to build up this clone in so
much across these episodes I just felt
like the payoff was nothing it was kind
of pointless and for no reason unless
you would see it somehow pop up again
because I just had so much Intrigue
about what moth given was doing and then
you just gets wiped out another thing
was there was no mythosol well sure we
had him teased at the end of episode
eight but we had him tease at the end of
episode two and it was teasing pretty
much the same way where he opens his eye
up in the water like I really felt like
we're going to see them if I saw in
action because it was teasing episode
two and nothing happened for the whole
entire season until he gets teased again
I feel like that was disappointing like
if this was going to be the case I
reckon we should have not showed the
Memphis or until the end of episode 8
like they did and then there would have
been more Hypes around in season four
people like oh my God remember the soul
is revealed we go to see him next season
blah blah blah but no we already knew
that from episode two the next thing I
want to talk about is the dark saber so
the darksaber has been a big build up
since the end of a season one when it
was revealed and then season two and
three when Boca time came into the
equation there's been a lot of build up
of her wanting to get a dark saber and
there's been a big build up of her you
know leading all over the man Lauren
claims with the dark saber and now when
all this has finally happened the
darksaber gets destroyed however I feel
like I might be in a little bit too
critical and I feel like there is a
chance that darksaber could be reforged
in season four at the end we see Paz
rizler's son being I guess baptized and
properly brought into the Creed but
there was no acknowledgment of Paz
wrestler's sacrifice and for the kid his
father just died and though you know
there is no acknowledgment of this at
all and I thought there's a little weed
and a little bit out of place again I
felt like the ride in this episode was
just weak they played it too safe and a
lot of that emotional weight that we had
in the previous season just seems gone
now like for example ig11 is back now
I'm personally not a fan of this it was
ig11 sacrifice at the end of season one
was just such a great animotional scene
but now all of our emotional weight is
just removed because you know he's back
in fully operational and while we're in
a topic of emotional weight the end of
season two was undone because grogu left
with Luke which is incredibly emotional
for us and for Manuel are in dangerous
but then it was really United with man
Lauren and not even in his own show and
there was just other little things in
this episode by doom and episode 4 when
the man's Orleans were chasing that big
bird Dragon thing and they're fuel in
their jet packs ran out well in this
episode we're the main Lawrence
basically fly from space just at the top
of the atmosphere and fly all the way to
the ground on Mandalore like that's a
pretty long journey you know for some
reason that was fine they didn't run out
of feel but then they just can't chase
the bird a little bit of inconsistency
there I would say and I've also seen
people saying that they thought the
Victorian guards died too easily I kind
of agree with that but I thought that
whole sequence was a fun sequence and
that was fine but I guess you could
argue this whole episode the good guys
did win too easily like you know that's
finally make an episode not as safe as
this and let's experience some loss I
thought we were going to experience some
lost in this episode because it was
teased that we were not going to be
ready for this episode and that we were
going to regret asking for more and
tears would be had but that did not
happen so I've rambled on for way too
long about this episode but I do have so
many more things to say so if you guys
want to see more videos on this then let
me know in the comment section below but
apart from that let me know your guys
thoughts in this episode below were you
guys a fan of this episode or were you
not thanks for watching guys